ya hemos visto antes en varios ejemplos
cómo hacer este tipo de cosas cómo
dividir 176 entre 8 por ejemplo y esta
vez bueno lo haremos nuevamente pero
esta vez vamos a entender e intentar
entender visualmente porque lo que
hacemos realmente funciona entonces
bueno lo lo hemos visto ya tomamos 176 y
lo dividimos entre 8 de hecho puedes
poner pausa el vídeo e intentarlo
entonces bueno en el pasado hemos
pensado cuántas veces cabe el 8 en una
ninguna así que nos enfocamos en el
siguiente dígito cuántas veces cabe el 8
en 10 y 72 veces 2 por 8 16 restamos nos
queda 1 y ahora bajamos el 6
entonces cuántas veces cabe el 8 en 16 2
veces 2 por 8 16 restamos y nos queda 0
y terminamos ahora para pensar en por
qué esto tiene sentido para pensar
porque tiene sentido esto voy a dibujar
un rectángulo entonces ok dibujo el
rectángulo
sabemos que el área de un rectángulo se
calcula base por altura entonces digamos
que su altura es 5 y el ancho mide 20
entonces 5 por 20 esto es igual a 100
entonces tengo 100 unidades cuadradas
como área de ese rectángulo entonces
pensemos en esto como un problema de
áreas bajas y si mis menciones son 8 y
algo más de mi rectángulo mi área debe
ser 176 entonces tengo aquí yo un
rectángulo ok si el área de este
rectángulo
176 y yo sé que una yo sé que una de mis
dimensiones es 8 ajá pero como puedo
averiguar cuánto mide el otro lado
entonces bueno digamos que la altura de
este rectángulo digamos que esto mide 8
la altura de este rectángulo mide 8 cómo
puedo yo averiguar cuánto mide este lado
si yo logro conocer eso entonces conocer
cuánto es 176 dividido entre 8 porque yo
sé que esto x 8 es igual a 176 ahora
dijimos que el 8 no caben 108 caben 17 2
veces ahora hay que poner aquí atención
porque en realidad me refería yo a 17
que está pasando detrás de todo esto
este este uno está en las centenas y el
7 en las decenas
esto es 170 en realidad lo que yo dije
fue que 8 caben 170 20 veces porque ese
no es un 2 el 2 está en las decenas es
un 20 así que 8 caben 170 20 veces voy a
borrar esto el área total sigue siendo
176 ajá pero lo que yo hice fue partir
esto en 176 así que así que lo voy a
partir
esto de aquí esto es 170 y esto es 6
esta sección tiene área de 170 y esto es
6 el área sigue siendo 176 como total
así que el área no se ha cambiado sigue
siendo la misma área en este rectángulo
ahora cuántas veces cabe el 8 en 170
cabe 20 veces entonces esto
esta longitud esto mide 20
esto me de 20 ok ahora lo que haremos es
sacar el área de ese rectángulo naranja
20 por 8 cuánto es eso voy a borrar esto
20 por 8 así que esto lo ancho lo ancho
mide 20 pongo aquí 2020 por 8 es 160 es
el área de ese rectángulo
esta área todo esto mide 160
esto es 160 unidades cuadradas
muy bien ahora puedes observar que aquí
está este 16 con el 1 en las centenas y
el 6 en las decenas
eso es 160 si restamos 160 de 170 que
obtenemos obtenemos 10 entonces entonces
eso quiere decir que esto está aquí eso
es un 10 así que esto esto mide diez
como área esto tiene 10 como área ahora
no hemos cambiado nada esto aún vale 176
tenemos 160 más 10 más 6
eso es igual a 176 entonces bueno 8 por
20 es 160 nos falta ver algo cuánto cabe
el 8 en lo que resta en este en este
rectángulo cuantas veces estaba el 8 en
lo que resta es 10 + 6 16 que sería que
sería este rectángulo en rosa es lo que
resta cuántas veces cabe el 8 en 16
bueno
este 16 es justamente justamente este 16
cuántas veces cabe el 8 en 16 sabemos
que cabe dos veces eso ya es exacto
entonces cuánto vale esto 20 más 2
eso es 22 que es justo lo que tenemos
acá y bueno pues ya terminamos con esto
ahora esto solamente fue para que lo
visualice yo sé que no vas a hacer esto
cuando tú hagas una división porque no
es muy práctico pero creo que queda la
idea y eso es lo que quería mostrar nos
vemos